when you saw you saw you know ben askren
going up there taking that you know i
saw you know brendan schaub says it's
not a dive i don't know what your
opinion on that is but i saw robbie
lawler put his fist for ben asking his
face and him not did not him not go down
so i don't know what your thoughts are
on ben askren versus jake paul if you
want to say him but
i mean
i don't know man
i don't know i mean look i'm not going
to take a dive i'm not going to let
somebody punch me in the face like that
and take a dive i mean i think jake just
really caught him really what about
tyrone woodley is there any chance he
took a dive because he got knocked out
nah jake jake caught him again
i mean listen i i i i hate to say it
because i was not
a fan of the jake paul the nepal
brothers doing anything but
they they wanted me over they they
really
you got to respect them you got to
respect them because
i mean it's not easy what they did you
know how bad would you mess up jake paul
i mean i like to believe i'll mess him
up pretty bad but i mean you know jake
is doing some things now you know what
i'm saying he's he's dude you're boxing
hall of fame
i'm just i'm just saying like i'm not a
boxer that's what i'm saying i'm not a
boss
what's the difference between the two
for those uh layman's uh out here uh
pace the timing the distance um you know
uh
the the the cadence of the punches you
know you know you got to be able to
understand that in order to you can't
just like jump into a boxing match and
just think that you've got a different
sport it's it's a totally different it's
a long drive competition compared to 18
holes of golf it's home run derby or
dunk contest compared to basketball you
have to have
you know to to go up against him you got
he's gonna he's gonna grapple you he's
gonna he's he's gonna strike from the
outside he's gonna kick you with your
legs from every angle i mean like the
amount of stuff that you have to prepare
for is insane like for instance like t
wood is known for that big overhand
right but that was predicated off of the
fact that he had the ability to take you
down yeah so you had to respect the fact
that he could take you down so when
you're not even worrying about that
you're just it's just straight back you
just trade boxing yeah so but by the way
so so here's a question you've got uh
francis who's destroying people right
with a swing and then you got tyson fury
who is undefeated and
one looks like a boxer the other one
looks like a bartender right even even
he posted a picture the other day says
this guy looks like a boxer this guy
does not but this guy whooped his ass
like that's what he said on his
instagram post but if but if a fury
today
fights francis boxing obviously in the
other area it's a different story but
it's in the boxing by the boxing rules
does tyson still win 100
100 i mean
listen listen listen as today right
right now i'm talking right now yeah
yeah i mean francis hasn't been boxing
right i mean listen francis can box but
to to
dismiss tyson fury just by the way his
body is you're dismissing his boxing
skill tyson fury is extremely fast he
has you know
very good footwork you know he has very
good setups with his punches i mean
deontay walder i mean his skill level
when it comes to showing the straight
ones and twos may not be the cleanest
but
he he can he can box you know what i'm
saying wilder why why why they can while
they're combining so maybe wilder
francis is a better fighter that would
be a better fight i see what you're
saying i think i think that
i think that i think that um
if if um
deontay walder and and uh and francis
fought i like francis in that fight over
wilder over wilder i like france in that
fight cause wilder throws some wild
punches when it comes
but if they connect you're going down
back to jake paul
he's just making mince meat of these ufc
guys you brought up uh ben affleck let's
get anderson
but let's talk boxers where is he in an
actual boxing match if he's fighting a
real boxer you know like i i don't know
if fury's brother's a good example and
his weight class too though adam because
he's been fighting people 20 where is he
in a real boxer okay something that i'm
clarifying right now is like all right
cool it's not the same thing boxing ufc
you know use the home run derby versus a
real baseball game if he fights a real
boxer where does that go
probably not well for him you know
because the truth of the matter is you
know he still makes a lot of amateur
mistakes when he's out there you know um
he's fighting exactly who he needs to be
fighting and i think this is the stick
that he needs to stick with because you
know uh
he doesn't need to be fighting
any real boxers that's been fighting
since they were kids because of the
truth that matters he he will get
exposed
in that respect you know he's got 40
million reasons to keep messing up ufc
guys huh i mean i guess he's supposed to
fight mike tyson soon so i don't know
about that
on that path i mean
that's that's what i heard i mean it but
if he fighting mike tyson yeah where you
at with that mike is going to destroy
him because mike mike don't play boxing
mike don't play boxing mike don't even
mike would destroy him
mike
listen mike is a different different
animal altogether mike is mike is
something different like mike is the
kind of guy who uh
like
he's he's he's become very civilized
but he's still very very savage
very savage but up until what age
meaning 55 mike tyson will mess him up
65 hours 55 he's seven years away from
getting social security
55 is 55 i don't know what we're talking
about he smokes a lot he takes a lot of
mushrooms so he's got a different
perspective i mean mike trains too mike
is micah's not just he doesn't
he doesn't just do it to you know to get
in shape for a fight mike is training
all the time he's consistently training
he's been able to you know find a second
win when it comes to training he's been
able to find a second win when it comes
to the love of the sport
which pushed him out of the boxing in
general but now he loves it again and
now that he loves it again
he's he's he's into it you know he's
into boxing and he's
but by the way would you would you make
the comparison of jon jones and mike
tyson more than jon jones and dennis
rodman
would you would you make that like
you know a personality the the more the
extracurricular activities outside of
the ring would you make that comparison
um i would say no i mean
because
knowing mike tyson
mike is a
he's a very cerebral guy mike is one of
the smartest guys that
that you that you're gonna that you're
gonna meet i would say when mike gets
himself in situations
is because he um
allowed himself to
uh like
get overwhelmed with a situation he
doesn't handle being overwhelmed really
well you know what i'm saying like mike
mike doesn't he doesn't you know that
pat and tyson were in the ring together
one time yeah it was pretty intense
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]